Care evolution also presented a PHR at the Dubfire applications round table.
The company says that it provides
secure interoperability solutions for population health management,
care coordination and consumer engagement.
Its myFHR, family health record app,
runs on the web and in iOS devices and leverages fire to enable consumers to
aggregate and manage their health data from
multiple hospital or physician office portals.
Consumers can view and manage their medications,
allergies and lab results.
The app also supports wearable sensors and connected devices,
such as glucometers, weight scales,
and blood pressure monitors,
provides notifications for upcoming appointments,
overdue preventive screenings and immunizations, and drug-drug interactions.
We will now see a video demonstration of myFHR provided for this course by the company.
Before we watch that video,
I would like to provide a personal note.
While I was still in training,
I cared for a patient who eventually died because he was
taking two simultaneous prescriptions for prednisone,
the steroid medication mentioned in the video.
A tool like myFHR might well have prevented that tragedy from occurring.